i don't have to  wear a watch when i'm hunting  it's just me my dogs  it's the life i want to live  today the ice is not farming anymore we  need to protect  the environment from the outside world  with the sea ice diminishing  the whole food chain is affected they're  all hunting grounds  they are just history now  everything is changing  i don't think we can underestimate how  profound an  impact past policies have been on the  arctic people  a quarter of all the unexploited oil and  gas reserves in the world are located in  the arctic  we're going to lose some species there's  no question about it  without animals we cannot survive  there certainly has been a breakdown of  our way of life  our language and our culture is so  connected to our land  our water and our ice  the stakes are so high for us  we're not going anywhere